we make way for the star center for the
utah jazz two-time defensive player of
the year
and owner of one of the great nicknames
in all the sports the stifle tower is
rudy gobert who joins us from orlando
good morning rudy how are you
good morning doing great how are you
where are you right now
in my room what do you have uh
in there that would be interesting
uh what do i have uh
probably my computer my computer my
gaming setup what do you play
uh right now i play call of duty you
know it's a
shooting game but but you don't play
basketball dude
you don't play video games with
basketball or madden do you do that
um i play a little bit of 2k but not a
lot right now
what about fans fifa i love football
[Laughter]
um what has life been like the last five
months if you were gonna try it if
somebody didn't know
your story hadn't talked to you how
would you sum up the last five months
uh a lot of
adventures i would say you know uh
a lot of things happen but you know uh
thankfully i mean uh
i'm in a great place right now you know
both physically and uh
and uh and mentally and you know i'm
excited to
to be back on the floor but take us back
to
that night uh in march like what went
through your mind
uh at the time and and what would you
have told
that rudy gobert if you had that
opportunity to go back in time
i mean obviously a lot of things were
going through my mind
you know protecting positive and
you know and all the all the things that
the domino effect that started but i
think you know
uh beside the the little
the little thing that happened like i
have no you know i stay myself
throughout this you know uh i kept doing
positive i kept you know
obviously there was a lot of fear you
know i didn't know what the virus really
was
it was tough to be away from my mom and
my family
because they weren't friends and they
couldn't come over and
you know because all the flights were
closed international flights
so you know it was it was a little tough
but you know i'm glad that i had people
around me that supported me and
uh you know uh i was able to get through
this and
you know i'm glad to be to be back right
now but also rudy at the time we didn't
know much about
the coronavirus and you know since you
tested positive
did you think that maybe there was a a
bigger health risk or that
you know that this could put you in the
hospital or how dangerous it was
i think really the the unknown part of
it
what was scaring me the most you know i
was uh
talking to different people across the
across the world before
italy france even china and uh you know
and there was a lot of uh
kind of like unexplainable things that
were
happening to some of the patients so you
know i was just that
i was just really worried that i could
be one of them you know so
i had to stay positive you know keep
trying to do the right thing
uh uh trying to make sure you know
uh i eat the right thing i pretty much
always do so you know yeah
keep keep staying positive especially uh
mentally and uh
you know and uh and just take the time
that i'm gonna need to recover
but also i wondered about you know what
kind of feedback you got because it felt
like you were being blamed
for ruining sports did you get that
feeling
um i mean uh i definitely had that
feeling on
social media you know people were
yeah i had a lot of messages very
negative messages and
[Music]
you know i try to put my mind away from
that because you know people are going
to judge without really knowing
what happened or knowing the situation
and at the same time you know there was
a lot of fear uh
you know there was a lot of anger you
know people were just like me you know
people were scared and uh
and uh you know someone always got to be
blamed it's
it's how it works why did you go on
social media
you know uh because i always i kind of
like to stay
connected you know trying to see what's
going on in the world try to see
you know i have a lot of friends that
are people that are that i appreciate
that uh that are following social media
too so
but you knew people are going to be
upset with you
maybe you didn't realize how upset they
were going to be with you but
you know everyone has an opinion and
you know when people most of the time on
social media people don't know
uh they just have a perception of you
it's based off perception something
that's been shown to them something that
you know they probably seen like they
will see one percent of what what you
are and judge you based on that one
percent
and you know i care about the people
that
know that the the hundred percent of
really i don't care
not that i don't care but like you know
i'm not trying to prove who i
am to to the rest of the people but the
most important thing is to stay true to
myself and
you know keep doing the positive that
i've been doing and that
i'm going to continue doing for my
communities and people around me
is rudy gobert the utah jazz center jazz
next game is against the pelicans
thursday
at uh 6 30 on uh tnt
yeah you start to look at this and then
they they health situation
uh do you have long-term health issues
or any uh
thing that's uh still lingering or
affecting you from
testing positive um i'm feeling good
right now
you know obviously the the sense of
smell
is still not back 100 percent but the
taste is back
uh the smell is back probably 80
you know so it's uh no i mean i'm in a
good place you know obviously there's
still a lot of things we don't know
about the long-term effect of the virus
but you know i'm uh
i'm just going to learn as we as we all
do as a
you know as a community who gave you the
nickname the stifle the tower
i think it's a big rider uh from south
lake city i think he's jody
his name is joey jealousy yeah maybe i'm
wrong but i think i think he found the
name
isn't there a fake eiffel tower in
orlando at epcot like can you look out
your
window can you see the uh the fake
eiffel tower
you know what let's take a look okay i'm
not sure
all right let's see if we can see the
eiffel tower at epcot
all right there you go looking out over
the lake
it's a nice view i don't see any
anything higher than the trees there
no you know yeah there's no eiffel tower
the fountain the gators
have you seen the alligators there in
the lake
i don't walk close to the water
that's very smart uh you're playing
against zion williamson here
uh coming up now if he goes up for a
dunk
being a two-time defensive player of the
year maybe going to win it again this
year
do you got to go after it
i'm always going to you know if i'm if
i'm in the right position obviously
i'm always going gonna i'm gonna try to
go and
and make a play but uh right what people
need to understand is sometimes like
sometimes i can
fall trouble sometimes you know you
don't wanna put yourself in certain
situations so it just depends on the
situations but yes
uh you know i'm definitely going to be
there to
to protect the basket i always love that
big men who challenge
that i know we talk about you get
posterized but
you also get blocked i mean you i don't
know i don't like when the big guy goes
he ducks down out of the way there are
certain times when i'm sure you did
but did you have one of those moments
they welcomed to the nba where you went
up to try to block somebody and it
didn't go well
uh yeah i mean people love to
love to pause those videos when when it
happens so yeah definitely you know i
mean uh
some a few guys done from me before and
and a few
and guys gonna don't come here again you
know it's part of the start of the life
of a
defensive player of the year you know
but i'm gonna keep uh
trying to do what's the best thing for
for my team defensively and uh
you know at the same time it's it's a
game you know it's
it's fun to it's fun to to accept the
challenge and sometimes you win
sometimes you lose
you know it's part of the game what's it
like with no fans
you know it's uh it's interesting but at
the same time
um i like what the nba has put together
you know i think uh i think uh the the
the screens
i was it was the feeling was a little
weird at first when i was shooting free
throws and i saw like all the different
faces behind
but uh you get used to it and i think it
can be a
it can be a fun thing i mean when you're
on the court you don't uh
it's great to have the the energy of the
fans but at the same time when you once
you focus on what you have to do you
know
you can zone out and we just focus on
the game it's got to be weird we're
going to be able to hear a lot of things
we normally don't get to hear rudy
i mean it could be it could be a there
might be some some cuss words and stuff
like that but
at the same time it could be a a pretty
uh
pretty cool thing for the fact that i
agree yeah but i think
if you're gonna curse do it in
i do french i mean it depends i try to
do it so the guy can understand
so he's a french guy
[Laughter]
there's no point so
he's an american guy yeah
if it was you know tony parker then you
might be able to say something then he
would understand
uh good luck with this rudy and uh no
it's been a long time
uh battling through this and uh you know
here we are
on the verge of restarting this season
so thanks for joining us we appreciate
your time thank you so much
i appreciate it that's rudy gobert the
uh
utah jazz center